all right so once in a while I talk
about trailers and this is gonna be one
of those days all right so I saw the
Green Lantern trailer this is one of the
most highly anticipated movies of this
coming summer summer 2011 has a lot of
high-profile movies this is pretty much
up there now this is just a teaser
trailer it's too early to tell what the
movies gonna be like if it's gonna be
good whatnot but the point of a teaser
trailer is to hype you up for the movie
and if that is the point this movie
trailer fails like a lot first off the
fake eye candy the Green Lantern suit
looks like CGI and it's not supposed to
I said they were gonna make the suit CGI
but they said it wasn't gonna look CGI
but it was the only way to make it look
like awesome and from another world or
some I mean the scene at the end of
the trailer is like now we could look
for trouble all I see are CGI arms on a
CGI body with a real head I think and I
understand the Green Lantern has a mask
it's part of his costume but in the
movie I hate the mask it looks more like
The Green Hornet than the Green Lantern
I mean does he need a mask Wolverine
didn't have a mask that worked fail on
the suit even if you like the mask and
now let's move on to the other fake eye
candy Blake Lively the girl only has two
lines in this trailer but when she spoke
them I thought one thing Wow Megan Fox
dyed her hair that's interesting and I
know Blake Lively's a good actress I saw
the movie the town so either they took
her two worst lines in the movie and put
them in the trailer or she's just not
good throughout I'm gonna go on a limb
bet that second one all right I saw a
fan trailer like a year ago and that was
really cool it was epic it got your
goosebumps going it even had the Green
Lantern's code so my frustration is the
actual trailer that's made by people who
do this for a living network at the
studio got one-upped by a fan made
trailer that came out of hirako if for
nothing else maybe that do should get a
job seriously Studios like hiram I don't
know who he is the higher arm but I will
say I've been wrong about movies based
on their trailers before I mean like
Iron Man when I saw the trailer for Iron
Man I thought to myself okay Robert
Downey jr. is gonna be funny the movies
gonna be like Fantastic Four with Iron
Man and then the Iron Man movie came out
you just absolutely just blew me away I
was dead wrong about that
so maybe the Green Lantern movie will
come out and just surprise me but as it
stands it's kind of like having to ride
a long car ride with your ex-girlfriend
it might surprise you and be really
pleasant but I mean deep down you just
know the movie just doesn't look like it
takes it like to that next level that I
think it should it's
Green Lantern is pretty iconic so did
you see the Green Lantern trailer yet
and what did you think of it and I put a
link to the fan-made trailer the better
trailer in the box below check it out
let me know what you think let me know
which one you like better you know how
it is it's all about the interaction
here on the Jeremy Jones YouTube
experience of Awesome TM and if you
liked this then click on this